so I want to play a fun game with you
called Hope Valley High I know there's
no high school in Hope Valley but it
kind of feels like you guys are always
together
it feels very much like a family like a
high school right I'm gonna read you a
few your castmates you're gonna tell me
what they'd be voted most likely to
great I'm excited okay it's a great game
Lori Lachlan best laughs best laughs
Lori Laughlin has a laugh that fills up
any room she's in
put her in a train station she will fill
up the entire thing it is the most
magical booming sweet cackle of a laughs
[Laughter]
most efficient what does that mean
meaning if there's a job she's getting
it done Miss Congeniality most loved so
youthful yeah oh she's aging backwards
as far as she's but she is it's likely
to start coughing up alone
Oh during a scene oh she does this call
it's unreal I was just talking about her
two nights ago uh help so I'm gonna give
her laws it doesn't matter she chokes on
air Jack Wagner most likely to grow up
to be a rock star best singing voice
yeah he's a great singer mm-hmm does he
sing for you a little on set he always
here I'm kind of he goes by my trailer
we share trailer that's like his is next
to mine I hear he has his guitar I have
my guitar we both have our guitar oh
yeah a little downtime jams we have
they're even stuck in snow together on
the highway and we passed the guitar
back and forth in the place that's how
we first got to know each other
silliest yeah yeah he's quite silly
unexpectedly most likely to do this a
lot Oh quintessential hair flip all the
time Erin Crapo most diversified with
the way that she plays Elizabeth with
the way that she plays Elizabeth with
the way she is on and off camera she can
be quiet and the next day she can be
dancing and you know you know poking the
butt with a fork kindest it's so kind
most likely to be my kid sister that's
so sweet
she's fantastic I love her to bits most
likely to hate you forever if you scare
her
Erin craco does not
like to be scared so you notice first
Laurie loves to be scared ok so you know
whose button oh yeah I still try what
happened when you're scared Aaron oh she
just gets so mad no oh who did it until
like kick graveling
she's not not happy Pascal Pascal Hutton
best smile that's true she's got great
teeth yeah a woman who is absolutely
nothing like her character really really
so maybe most surprising most surprising
I love that most likely to be one of my
very best friends
Kevin's best chef Oh is he cooking like
he wins the whole Mecca Ward but he does
cook for us sometimes he's pretty
amazing some risotto you made a note
baby it's a little fancy most likely to
know how to bake you a croissant from
scratch can do anything in the kitchen
that's frustrating it's like a as close
to a cordon bleu trained chef as you can
get a guy that laughs a lot dresses
goofy and should be laughed at
most comedic yep pain enough
[Music]